[Music]
the importance of gender in research is
increasingly in the spotlight but what
does this mean for horizon 2020 funded
research to begin with we must
distinguish between gender balance
within research teams and the need to
address gender aspects in the research
itself under horizon 2020 the European
Commission is fostering equal
opportunities within research teams and
gender balance in the decision-making
processes
this means that research and project
management teams should be made up of a
balanced number of women and men the
European Commission also hires experts
of both sexes to ensure gender balance
in its panels now let's focus on the
integration of gender sex analysis in
research itself this is what we call the
gender dimension in research and
innovation content
[Music]
why should you be aware of it
simply put incorporating a gender aspect
in research where relevant improves the
scientific quality and societal
relevance of the results there's a lot
of waste of time and resources because
things are done in a wrong way and
that's due to for example gender blind
the research in in health sciences in
transport or in in welfare we have the
male as the norm we use him as a
representative for the whole adult
population I think that these
perspectives need to be broadened and
this would be for the good the common
good and and also advance the well-being
of all of us you have in your proposal
to think about being creative think
alternatively in the future maybe we can
find new
things are new issues to study because
you dare to focus on something that has
not been the tradition exploring the
gender dimension offers a lot of
potential even in areas that may seem
gender-neutral at first sight like
transport or climate change did you know
that cars were only tested on male
crash-test dummies ignoring risks of
injuries for women all those women were
more vulnerable than men to the effects
of climate change because they
constitute the majority of the world's
poor and are more affected by the lack
of Natural Resources these examples show
that sex and gender both biological and
socio-cultural considerations can matter
a lot when considering the gender
dimension we must differentiate between
gender and sex and take into account the
way these two notions interact with each
other
[Music]
gender dimension is the umbrella night
name for both the social structure
gender and sex there is a growing
recognition that it's very hard to
differentiate and say this is pure six
and this is pure gender there are lots
of presumes and perhaps one should also
take them into account recognizing how
gender and sex influence culture and
society is critical if we want research
to be more effective it is likely to
require extra time and resources but
it's also a powerful way to question
stereotypes and address that distinct
needs of women and men so do you think
the gender dimension is relevant and
applicable to your research or not let's
have a closer look at some examples when
it snows the streets are plowed so that
people can get through at first sight
you could think that this has nothing to
do with gender and yes the community of
karlskoga in sweden realized that this
issue might not be gender neutral a
study showed that major roads for cars
were cleared first and only then streets
bus stops pedestrian walkways and bike
paths
it was also shown that women walk cycle
and use public transport more often than
men in other words the way the
municipality cleared up the snow favored
car users and therefore had different
effects on women and men this was not
intentional of course they were just
doing things the way they've always been
done this led to a reconsideration of
their snow clearing approach the
municipality changed its priorities and
started to clear pedestrian walkways and
bike paths before roads they also gave
priority to schools and major employers
before major roads this new organization
more in line with people's daily
schedules made the city more accessible
to everybody including children people
with pushchairs walkers and wheelchairs
and it didn't cost anything the
municipality just shifted the schedules
around he changed actually benefited the
city's economy by reducing the costs of
injuries and accidents due to slippery
conditions
studies have shown that in many parts of
the world women and girls are in charge
of washing cooking cleaning or fetching
water they often have to go miles to do
these tasks this is a burden that stops
them doing other things such as going to
school improving education without also
improving water infrastructure therefore
tends to favor the education of boys
it's also been shown that many
development projects run by
international institutions fails because
women were excluded from the
decision-making process and their
knowledge remained unused yet research
projects that include a gender
perspective and women proved successful
why is this so simply because women
control on their daily experience of
using water which is richer than that of
men they know the soils and their water
yields are more aware of the physical
burden of carrying water and the
associated injuries and accidents
projects in which women were trained to
maintain infrastructures or in which
they were included as advisors to
engineers have made water sources more
reliable and improved access to water
for everyone
as a result they have improved girls
school attendance and enabled adult
women to take on activities that bring
in money helping to break the cycle of
poverty now that you know what the
gender dimension in researches take a
few minutes to consider how gender and
sex could influence your research
outcomes
[Music]
researchers should think of the chain
that I mentioned not as an emergency as
it is now research teams often you know
realize somewhere in the research
process oh we need again that I mention
here because European Union tells us to
do that
I think they shoot him and this is also
what is implied in the horizon 2020 it
should be included right from the
beginning throughout the process of
research and then also in the design of
the end result to our applicants who
would like to consider gender in their
project I suggest that I try to really
think how can they
concretely contribute to the cause maybe
go read and studied the documents that
EU published in the UN and you fight
great deal of information and
inspiration there to actually make your
contribution valuable and real if you're
applying for an MSC a grant or another
horizon 2020 project think about how the
gender dimension is relevant to your
proposal and if so explain how the
gender dimension will be evaluated under
the excellence criterion addressing sex
and gender aspects will improve the
quality of your research and could make
a difference visa vie other applicants
by taking into account the gender
dimension in your project the knowledge
your work will produce will be more
relevant for society and ultimately lead
to better science
[Music]